تمثل المنتجعات البحريه ابرز الوجهات
السياحيه المفضله للشباب والعائلات من
مختلف الجنسيات في السعوديه بغرض
الاستمتاع وقضاء اجمل الاوقات والسبب يعود
الى الخدمات الترفيهيه الفاخره التي
توفرها تلك المنتجعات مثل الرياضات
البحريه والمطاعم والمقاههي المزيد مع علي
النقبي
السياحيه توفرها المنتجعات البحريه بشرق
السعوديه والتي يقصدها السياحه من مختلف
الجنسيات للاستمتاع باجوائها والاقامه
فيها كما تعرف السياحه في المنتجعات
البحريه هي موسميه فلذلك الاقبال جميل جدا
عليها و باذن الله نتامل اكثر الان مع
موسم كاس العالم ومع الاجازات القصيره
الكثيره في خلال السنه المنتجه يوفر في
خدمات كثيره خاصه في الاونه الاخيره وتطور
من الاماكن الرئيسيه اللي في توفير
الخدمات همم تزيين الاماكن العامه فكان
هذا سبب رئيسي لوجودنا اليوم في هذا
المكان
نفتقد لبعض الاماكن اللي زي كذا عندنا في
الرياض
فالجنا الاماكن هذه او همم التواجد في همم
في الاماكن الرائعه والجميله هذه هي لمه
العائله او لمتمه همم الاسره او الاسره
حول المنتجعات البحريه وخياراته ترفيهيه
للش جوه العائله منها الرياضات البحريه
والمطاعم والمقاهي والعديد من وسائل
الترفيه المكان يجمع بين شباب وعوائل وفي
اللي مهتم في الالعاب البحريه المهتم في
الحدائق مهتم جلسات البحر والشوي والاشياء
هذه كلها موجوده يلا يا ربي لك الحمد
في الشواطئ نظيفه في ما شاء الله القوارب
المائيه في الاشياء هذه تخلي الانسان يدفع
فلوس اسمه مجرد واحد
يسوي كثير حلو حبيت كثير
لا الازبال الحلوه اللي عاملينها اللعب
للاولاد
المسابح المطاعم كل شيء هون حلو
الشرقي وفي السعوديه ومستهدفا ناجحا
للسياحه بفضل منتجاته المثلى ابرزها سياحه
المنتجعات احدى العوامل المحفزه لجذب
المزيد من الفرص الاستثماريه من الناطقه
الشرقيه عن اللقب العربيه